go hi there Steve again and hello Kieran
and we're going to go over your
questions which we've collected now I
can't answer all the questions but I've
collected them to some extent and we're
going to hopefully answer most of the
questions so go ahead shoot here okay so
the first one writing systems cause
problems in language learning how do you
deal with different writing systems in
Chinese and Russian etc and it's up to
exactly Korean and I remember the
question was how do you select Chinese
how do you start listening and reading
when you can't read anything with
Chinese what I did when other Chinese I
spent the first month only sort of
listening and using pinion in those days
was a different system for you know
using a Roman or Latin alphabet so I
listened and I read in the romanization
system that we use at that time and then
after a month I heavy-duty into learning
the characters and I learned the first
thousand most frequently used characters
as a deliberate exercise I would study
ten eventually 30 a day forget them reel
ER in them separate from my reading in
this thing after about a thousand
characters I just learned the letter
that characters as I went but with a
character based writing system you have
to make a deliberate effort to learn the
characters once you get to a phonetic
writing system like Mike Cyrillic script
for Russian is really not very difficult
because it's kind of almost parallel to
the Latin alphabet with a few other
symbols so basically you learn it you
don't really understand that you start
reading it's difficult to read you
continue reading and listening and
gradually it becomes more and more
comfortable the same is true for say the
Korean script or the condo script in
Japanese those are easier to get used to
and you get used them as you read but
where you have characters to learn
anessa that's a big chore you have to do
it and you have to do it every day and
consistently for a good you know few
months okay so next one in English the
spelling is so irregular the
pronunciation becomes a problem how do
you deal with that
we got a bit of a message coming in yeah
in English that's almost another
situation where the writing system is
different from the way the language is
pronouncing someone asked me to use the
international phonetic alphabet I don't
but maybe if you know as my approach to
language learning is whatever works for
you I'm not interested in learning
another writing system because I have to
get used to how those characters symbols
are used to represent these sounds so I
listen to the sounds and I see how its
represented in that language and I try
to get used to it so yeah with English
you just have to get used to the fact
that you know Oh ugh can be though wow
you're all tough rough through just have
to get used to it and so personally I
don't use the IPA international
fanatical phonetic alphabet but some
people love it so much a matter of
choice alright alright so here's another
good one I'm learning English in
Vancouver most graded readers use the
British accent is this a problem if I
want to learn to speak with the North
American accent okay the issue of
accents comes up all the time not only
in English not in Spanish in Portuguese
there's many languages where you know
the pronunciation can vary from region
to region that is to say that native
speaking you know pronunciation
personally I don't worry about it my
main job when I start learning a
language is to make sure i can
understand and that I accumulate a large
vocabulary so typically for spanish for
example i want to make sure that i can
understand someone from mexico from
argentina from spain in portuguese
someone from brazil and purport to go
however I then decide which
pronunciation is the most useful to me I
see if I'm going to be working in Quebec
I want to learn commack pronunciation if
I'm going to be working in Brazil I want
to learn Brazilian Portuguese so then I
focus for the purposes of imitating the
accent I focus on those sources that
speak the way and i want to speak and i
try to imitate them but i don't limit
self to that i actually will deal with a
large variety of content and typically
the vocabulary is extremely similar
between you Portugal Brazil Mexico Spain
Quebec France is largely the same okay
okay so someone here who's using link
says how many times should I study a
lesson question should I focus on
grammar vocabulary structure how do I
proceed okay in link or if you're
learning not using link I believe that
listening and reading is the most
powerful way to learn the language to
bring it in subconsciously and this is
what I'm doing with polish with the
wonderful material that donor has
developed I don't focus on should I
learn the conjugation should I learn the
structure while I'm listening though and
typically with like what I'm doing with
polish I'll often use the sentence view
in our I link on my iPad and then I can
really look at the structures to remind
myself to help my brain learn but it's
not as if I'm I'm sort of blocked
studying conjugation tables because I
find that very often I wouldn't say it's
a waste of time but its its limit
limited in what it can do for you okay
usually I'll refer to these and quickly
forget it and so the bulk of my time is
spent listening reading and of course
creating links saving words and phrases
on link and so you're just following the
content reading or listening to the
content learning about other things and
subconsciously absorbing the language
and as to how many times again it's up
its up to you typically when I start I
listen often to the same material but
don't understand it very well and as I
progress in the language I listen less
frequently to the same lesson and
basically I move on at link when I'm
bored okay I don't have to understand
seventy percent or eighty percent when
I'm tired of the lesson I move on
because it's all exposure yeah that's a
good idea so when you're reading do you
ignore words and phrases that you find
difficult to understand absolutely i'll
look up the word i might look up three
or four words it still doesn't make
sense I can't make sense of this
sentence I can't make sense of the
lesson
don't worry about it I'm confident than
my experience tells me three months from
now that'll all makes sense right now it
doesn't make sense there's no use
beating your head against a brick wall I
just move on okay so 11 a person's
asking here they have online discussions
with a spanish-speaking language partner
his English is much better than my
Spanish I'm too embarrassed to speak
Spanish what should i do you know when
we speak to foreign language we are
embarrassed you don't speak as well as
in our own language if you want to be
totally comfortable sound intelligent
and all the rest of it stay with your
native language when you speak a foreign
language you're going to sound dumb
you're going to sound like a child
you're going to make mistakes that's
part of the package you just have to do
it and I'm sure that your language
partner is quite content to you know
patiently talk to you in Spanish and
then you know of course help him or her
with her English and that's the deal so
what can I say just you have to break
through that initial sense of
embarrassment and once you get
comfortable using your new language and
congratulating yourself for what you're
able to do rather than worrying about
the mistakes that you made you'll find
that you'll develop this new habit of
speaking with mistakes and enjoying it
okay and last one here how do you get
motivated to learn a new language
related to that what about learning two
languages at the same time and what
about learning dead languages like Latin
or ancient Greek or ancient Greek yes
alright the motivation is your interest
so if I'm interested in ancient Greek
and Latin I'm going to go after them we
have Latin at link we don't have ancient
Greek but the learning process is the
same I don't know if there's audio
available for ancient Greek there is
audio available for Latin and we're
using it at Lee learning two languages
at the same time if you're learning them
both from scratch and it's difficult I
don't do it because I find that once i
get motivated to learn a language I'm so
motivated that I want to spend all my
time on that language so I really don't
have much time for a second language
but I I don't think it's bad for you to
learn two languages at the same time in
fact to some extent it may help you it
might be very good for the brain to keep
things fresh but because motivation is
such a big part of language learning in
fact if I motivated like now to do
polish I find it very difficult to take
time away to spend on my Korean for
example okay well that's heavy okay I
hope we answered every question and
continue on your 90 day challenge see
you guys next time